we just got a massive exclusive leak
about Apple's new M2 Pro and Max MacBook
Pros and the new Mac minis coming sooner
than you think specifically by the end
of January an exclusive Source who
wishes to be anonymous just reached out
to me with some information that I've
never heard anywhere yet until now now
I've got to say that I've never heard of
this guy before and I have no way of
confirming his identity or information
so take all of this with a grain of salt
but as he started telling me more and
more info about this release and how he
got the information the puzzle pieces
started coming together and actually
making a lot of sense so in this video
I'm gonna First share the details and
specs of these new Macs and then I'll
get into the eight hints explaining why
this could actually make a ton of sense
so let's begin first up we have the new
Mac Mini which will offer either an M2
Chip like we have in the current MacBook
Air or a new M2 Pro chip which perfectly
lines up with rumors from Mark German
and other sources now in terms of the
specs he said that the storage for the
Mac Mini would range from 256 gigs to 8
terabytes of SSD storage which actually
makes sense because the M1 Pro 14 inch
MacBook Pro currently goes up to 8
terabytes now as for the ports it'll get
two USB a ports an HDMI and ethernet
port as well as up to four Thunderbolt
ports which confirms that the M2 pro
model will replace the current Intel
model keep in mind that this is
completely unchanged from the current
models which points to Apple reusing the
same design as the current Mac Mini
which was leaked by matrico last year in
March and Mark German also agreed that
there will not be a redesign for this
Mac Mini update now as far as the new M2
Pro and M2 Max MacBook Pros he says that
everything is basically saying the same
including the same as SSD options the
three Thunderbolt ports the SD card slot
and a lot of the other specs except for
a couple of key details the memory
options will range from 16 gigs to 96
gigs of RAM which matches up to recent
geekbench leaks that we've seen and the
battery life will be 18 hours for the 14
inch and 22 hours for the 16 inch and
I'm going to explain why that's so
important in just a minute but the
biggest piece of info he leaked was the
release date by the end of January and
now some of you might think that's crazy
but I've been putting some puzzle pieces
together and it actually makes sense so
before I jump into the eight different
hints at why this could happen if you're
a Mac User who does any sort of work
with documents spreadsheets or
slideshows on your Mac are sponsor
software keep is giving our viewers 25
off on genuine Microsoft software like a
one-time purchase of Microsoft Office
for Mac which includes word excel and
PowerPoint now there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who sells only 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over a hundred thousand
five star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and their customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you'll talk to a real
person instead of a robot so if you have
any questions they'll be glad to help so
buy Microsoft Office for Mac or anything
else you need today and save 25 off
their already great prices with their
New Year's promo by using the link in
the description and the coupon code
mtyt25 now let's jump back into the
first hint at a January launch date
actually making sense we've seen quite a
lot of speaks about a January event
which is really unusual but that got
shot down because we thought it was
meant for the Apple VR headset release
but now that it's getting delayed until
the end of the year
WWDC in June makes the most sense for
that VR headset reveal so what if all of
the leaks and rumors about a January
event was simply just for a press
release for these new Macs now getting
into hit number two January is a pretty
weird time to release Max so it doesn't
really make much sense however we were
actually expecting these MacBook Pros
and Mac minis to get released in
November but they were delayed for some
reason and because of that delay we
figured that the M2 Pro and M2 Max ships
would be built on tsmc's brand new three
nanometer process which would be the
reason for the delay and that would put
the release schedule at around March
when Apple usually has a Mac focused
event however some recent leaked
benchmarks of the M2 Max chip from early
December point to scores not being good
enough to be on three nanometer chips so
it's most likely gonna be four nanometer
just like the a16 also if the new
Macbook Pros were getting revealed in
March it would be weird for benchmarks
to leak so early in December three and a
half months early that usually doesn't
happen on top of that our exclusive
Source says that apple had people sign
ndas around the same time as the M2 Max
benchmarks were leaked on December 8th
so maybe that's when people started
testing them out now for hit number
three on December 18th Mark Goodman said
that the new Macbook Pro Models would
launch in early 2023 which is
interesting wording since he could have
said spring 2023 for March which he has
said for other products but this time he
specifically said early
2023 so maybe that means one of his
sources gave that information to him and
he wasn't sure exactly when it would
release which could point to January as
a hint now for hint number four Amazon
currently has a sale on the 14-inch
MacBook Pro for only sixteen hundred
dollars which is the best price ever
even better than Black Friday and then
on top of that the current 16 inch M1
Max model is 500 off only three thousand
dollars and usually these kinds of crazy
sales hints at new products coming now
for hint number five I believe it makes
the most sense for this release to be a
press release because of a few important
reasons the M2 Pro and empty Max chips
are likely to be very similar to the
first gen chips built on four nanometer
which is basically third generation five
nanometer in the eyes of tsmc so there's
going to be little changes except for
being faster and a bit more efficient
and that actually perfectly adds up to
the battery life numbers that the source
gave me an extra hour of battery life
for each the 14 and 16 inch models and
that matches up to four nanometer chips
and not three nanometer which would give
it even better battery life than that
even further the overall designs and
displays are staying basically identical
on both the MacBook Pros and the Mac
minis so we have no changes expected at
all on the outside and an update like
this does not warrant dedicated time
during an official Apple event this is
why the recent M2 iPad Pro was a press
release now we were expecting these
machines to be revealed at Apple's March
event but if they're not big enough
changes to Warrant an event then they
should probably just be a press release
anyway now for hit number six I still
expect an Apple event in March so what
is going to be released then well Mark
German recently revealed a huge piece of
info on Twitter the Apple silicon Mac
Pro which is expected to get released
between now and the summer has been
tested on Mac OS 13.3 which Mark German
says usually gets released in the spring
and that is perfect time for a March
event why well I believe that Apple's VR
headset is going to be the focus of WWDC
in June since it's going to require a
lot of attention from software
developers which is the entire point of
WWDC that's why Apple revealed the Apple
silicon transition at wwc in 2020 before
waiting half a year to actually release
the first Apple silicon M1 Max and I
think the story is going to be the same
for the VR headset and on top of that
the Apple silicon Mac Pro of course
deserves to have its own event because
it's the last Mac to transition over to
Apple silicon which puts it in the
spring timeline and also that Mac is
expected to come with the M2 Ultra chip
and that chip absolutely must get
revealed after the M2 Pro and M2 Max are
revealed since it's a higher end chip
this adds weight to the new Macbook Pros
and Mac minis getting press released
before the March event and finally we
also got leaks of the 15-inch MacBook
Air and that would be a perfect consumer
focused Mac to get released alongside
the Mac Pro at the March event now for
hit number seven I have to explain why I
believe so strongly that these releases
will be a press release the main reason
is that the MacBook Pro is barely being
changed we got the same design same
displays same ports just basically a
chip swap to M2 Pro and M2 Max and
probably upgraded Bluetooth 5.3 and
Wi-Fi 6E specs and on top of that the
Mac Mini is expected to keep the same
chassis as we currently have right now
the M2 Chip is going to be a very easy
chip swap and even the M2 Pro chip
should be fine in the current chassis
believe it or not why well because
there's a huge amount of empty space in
the current M1 Mac Mini Apple can easily
utilize the extra space for a larger
cooling system if it needs to to cool
down the M2 Pro and also the same exact
power supply from the Intel i7 model is
more than enough to power the M2 Pro
chip without any issues due to Apple
silicon efficiency and now finally for
hit number eight the only other option
for these releases would be that Apple
would launch all three Macs at the March
event like leaks Apple Pro exclusively
leaked however I highly doubt that they
would release all three at once
especially two desktop Macs the Mac Mini
and and the Mac Pro which clash with
each other that's just simply too many
Macs to launch at once Apple would
potentially be losing sales since there
are so many choices of the same product
at one time on top of that they'd be
revealing the MC Pro M2 Max and M2 Ultra
chips all in one event that is extremely
unlikely because Apple split those
reveals up with the first gen M chips
and seeing as the M2 extreme is now
likely canceled they would be revealing
the rest of the entire M2 family of
chips in a single day which I doubt so
because of that I fully expect the Mac
Pro to be revealed at a separate time at
the March event and that of course means
that the MacBook Pros and Mac minis
should be revealed before then making a
press release perfect for this type of
release and since the new M2 Pro and
match chips likely won't be based on
three nanometer chips why wait longer to
release them making by the end of
January a possibility for this release
of course with a grain of salt so let me
know if you think all of this adds up
and makes sense or not down in the
comment section below and if you'd
rather buy a new 14-inch MacBook Pro for
only sixteen hundred dollars right now
you can use the YouTube product tagging
feature below to check it out and click
that Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]